now this is a frequency table you've had
to construct some of these in the
previous exercise you may have had to
have had like an extra column for
tallying and then you can warm up by the
end and this is what your result with
okay now frequently in fact one of the
actual questions on this is on the basis
of your frequency table on the basis of
those guys over there
in extra Brian can you add on columns
for cumulative frequency and relative
frequency alright so how are we going to
calculate these things now there's
actually an order to this so I'll leave
this up in a minute so you can enjoy
your own when it's on but I just want
you to focus first it makes more sense
to work out cumulative frequency first
rather Drella to frequency and as we go
through it I wonder if you can work out
y-cubed a frequency let me come back to
our definition here right of cumulative
frequency it's the total up to and
including each one of those points okay
so now if I have a look here candy
clicks some kind of lollies I have no
idea okay
why don't we have accumulated frequency
I'm just looking at this column over
here for normal frequency and I'm adding
it up as I go so the first one would be
1 the second one it's going to be 1 plus
5 which is 6 the next one's going to be
6 plus 8 which is 14 plus 13 which is 27
34 38 okay good so I want you to look at
these numbers now I hope this sort of
rings a bell in terms of its similarity
with when we were constructing field
diagrams do you remember that we'll walk
across the field and we'd be counting
this the trundle wheeled as a ticked
over and you're gonna get these numbers
that get bigger and bigger and bigger
right now how does that relate to these
numbers over here well those numbers on
the left are the ones which is like the
differences between those okay so all
I've done to get the column on the right
is to add up those differences okay now
can anyone tell me why it makes sense to
work out cumulative frequency before
relative frequency if you need to work
out by cut maybe carry back to the
definition for relative frequency might
help
yeah very good so if you have a look at
the definition right to find relative
frequency you need the total population
maybe it's something divided by
something and you don't know what the
total population is till you've counted
them up so when I come here I've worked
out that the total is 40 so now this is
as simple as it gets I'm going to write
each one as a fraction 36 candy cooks it
happens once out of 40 that's it I could
write that that's the two-and-a-half
percent they might ask you for a
percentage it doesn't matter too much
this is going to be 5 out of 40 which I
can simplify this will be 8 out of 40
which I can also simplified 13 out of 4
you can I simplify that one nope 13 is
prime so I'm stuck 7 out of 40 can I
simplify no 4 out of 42 one on 10 and
then lastly 2 out of 40 which is okay
and I'm done I've got all my things here
now you can see I've got some questions
down here I'll only answer just one of
them really if I said how many packets
contained 40 or fewer right so what I'm
doing is I'm looking at the cumulative
frequency in saying well where's 40 and
where is all of the ones including that
40 or fewer
so here's 40 34 that 34 includes all of
these numbers does that make sense so my
simple answer to how many packets
contain 40 or fewer the answer is 34 34
of them contained 36 or 37 or 38 that's
what the adding did for me okay